الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يشن حربا
وحشيه على اوكرانيا ويستهدف بها جماته
مصادر الماء والكهرباء والتدفئه ويستخدم
الشتاء كسلاح هذا ما اعلنه الامين العام
لحلف شمال الاطلسي لدى وصوله الى رومانيا
لحضور اجتماع وزراء خارجيه دول الناتو
مؤكدا ان دول الحلف ترسل الامدادات الى
اوكرانيا وتتطلع الى اعاده بناء البناء
التحتيه في هذا البلد الاوروبي
قمنا بتسليم مولدات كهربائيه
ويتابع الحلفاء تقديما مساعده بطرق مختلفه
لاعاده بناء البناء التحتيه المدمر نحن
بحاجه الى ان نعيه الاثار الهائله الهجمات
التي تسببت في اضرار كبيره اعتقد اننا
راينا جميعا تلك الصور الماخوذه من
الاقمار الاصطناعيه وكيف ترى اوروبا مضاءه
واخرانيه مظلمه وما يترتب على ذلك من
نتائج سيئه امامنا مهمه هائله
عادت بنائه لهذا
وزراء وخارجيه دول الناتو يسعون الى
التوافق على زياده المساعده العسكريه
لاوكرانيا مثل انظمه الدفاع الجوي
والذخيره وما يصفونه بالمساعدات غير
الفتاكه
سنتفق وامول ان نتفق على تقديم حزمه كبيره
للغايه من المساعده غير الفتاكه لاوكرانيا
لمساعدتها على اجتياز صعوبه هذا الشتاء
يشاركوا بالاضافه الى اعضاء دول الناتو
وزراء خارجيه اوكرانيا وفنلندا والسويد في
اجتماع الثلاثاء على ان ينضم وزراء خارجيه
البوسنه والهرسك وجورجيا ومالدافيا الى
اجتماعيه يوم الاربعاء